the Joe Rogan experience I worked for
him in like 97 back in 97 that was like
the first time I ever worked for him but
uh he was then that was when Drew Carey
had the Drew Carey Show right and Drew
Carey had got him apart on The Drew
Carey Show and he was like God for the
[ __ ] for a goof now now do [ __ ]
acting yeah and he wasn't being like a
real actor and then all of a sudden I
see him on the [ __ ] Sopranos I was
like holy [ __ ] you're on the greatest
show in the history of the universe yeah
yeah and he was really good oh yeah but
it's substantiate of my feelings about
acting but it's just pretending yeah
it's not that hard I mean there's acting
like did you see the Joker yet no holy
[ __ ] I saw the other night Jamie you
were right holy [ __ ] Joaquin Phoenix is
a [ __ ] master
oh yeah it's a masterpiece now I love
the money Johnny Cash yeah why I'm like
maybe I am
I mean it's a [ __ ] up sick movie yeah
but it's that's what they were trying to
do right it's the greatest [ __ ] up
sick movie I think I've ever seen I mean
you might not be into it if you're not
into the whole us I'm sure listen to me
I enjoy anything that's done well yes
you know I mean even if it's not my cup
of tea yeah you know I mean I'll I'll go
and I'll watch it and I'll try to figure
out what what the message you were
trying to get a point and maybe I can
connect with your vision I'll give you
that and if it sucks I'll just come yeah
it's not for me but some master yeah
it's a masterpiece I mean Todd Phillips
nailed it and walking free Todd Phillips
as a master of comedy does this it's one
of the dark movies is not a funny
[ __ ] moment in that movie huh he's
not a happy moment in that movie but
it's a masterpiece but the point is like
that kind of acting like what Joaquin
Phoenix does in that movie what Daniel
day-lewis doesn't his movies like that's
on another level
but like regular acting like look what
Steve did they gave him a fat suit right
they put a fat suit on him and he played
Bobby on The Sopranos and he [ __ ]
nailed it he knocked out of the park you
would think that that guy had been
acting his whole life right you really
would he wasn't
[Applause]